after george floyd was killed by derrick
shoven the police officer in minneapolis
and there were
protests that broke out in cities around
the world especially cities around the
united states and some of those protests
turned violent
and there was riotous behavior and
assaults on police officers and there
was arson and looting
and there was there was general disorder
and it's a big political football and
people are on all sides of it and
they're defenders of it and so forth and
so on
but it occurred to me
that i did not even know
that the incident that happened with a
white police officer and the black
gentleman who died who was killed was a
racial incident i i say i did not know
that it was a racial incident all i knew
was that the police officer was white
and that the man who was killed was
black
it didn't follow from that
that it was a racial incident we were
making it into a racial instead we being
all of us here in the united states we
were making it into a reenactment of old
american dramas of lynching and the
murder of black people by rogue police
and
so forth and so on
we
took that thing
and we said yes see here we have proof
of the knee on the neck of black america
that's what
al sharpton the activist said at the
funeral of joyful he said america has
its knee on our neck and i thought
this great country of 330 million people
with 40 million black people
and here we are
150 years after slavery in a half
century since martin luther king was
killed
really
that's going to be the narrative for our
country's politics for the next uh
decade for the next 15 years this is
what we're going to teach to our
children this is how we're going to
arrange our
media coverage of these events this is
that's a disaster for this country okay
so how how can you say that when you
also have spoken so eloquently on topics
such as the differential incarceration
rate this is not an assault on your
statement by the way i'm very curious
because
obviously you know you've spoken
profoundly about the danger of that
differential incarceration rate and you
can see that it's not that easy to
conceptually disentangle especially if
you're politically motivated but even if
you're not the the an event like that
from that broader narrative that
something you know something's not right
structurally and perhaps this is a
reflection of it
but
well so i i don't know how to reconcile
those two viewpoints i don't know how
you reconcile them
with difficulty i suppose i could say
because they do point in slightly
different maybe even more than slightly
different directions but i'm trying to
keep my perspective
right i i do think that the uh advent of
what they call mass incarceration two
and a quarter million people under lock
and key on a given day half of them are
45 of them being black people when we're
12 of the population
uh as a way of doing business going
forward without any
uh sense of
urgency of reform without any revisiting
of you know our drug laws or our
sentencing or whatever without any uh
attention to what is supposed to happen
when someone is in prison rehabilitation
and whatnot without any exploration of
alternatives to incarceration as ways of
responding to criminal offending is bad
for our country i do believe that and i
believe the racial aspect of that echoes
with our history in ways that are
uh that are uh dangerous and that we
dare not neglect i i'm the same guy
on on the other hand i think
if you racialize the discussion of crime
and punishment um there was the woman
who was murdered at columbia university
a few years ago and her
she was killed by these kids who were
just trying to rob her and they ended up
stabbing her to death she was white she
was uh you know
i'm sorry i don't remember her name
offhand
but you know she was uh a lovely young
woman and innocent is how she's going to
appear in the photograph and she
certainly did nothing to deserve what
befell her and she was white
the great
the other side of it yeah right
tessa tessa something is her last name i
can't recall the kids who killed her
were black kids from around harlem
they were in the park yeah they were
looking for a quick score they had a
knife the woman is lying she bleeds out
now they've convicted one of them has
been convicted and i'm looking at the
photo in the newspaper and here's this
black kid he looks like a black kid
who's
16 18 years old he's a kid
he's from this impoverished neighborhood
he's black
and the woman is white
i don't want that incident processed in
terms of black kid murders white women
yeah yeah okay so maybe it's an issue
maybe it's an issue of conflation
careless conflation of levels of
analysis eh
because
you you you're talking about
a high-resolution analysis of structural
problems in the in the penal system and
to to put that george floyd event to
cram that into the same narrative it
sort of be speaks of undifferentiated
thought and so and then you point out
that the danger of that is well if
you're going to racialize the white cop
against the black
black victim of of the of the of the
homicide well then why can't the same
thing be done exactly the same way when
the reverse happens and maybe we
shouldn't do any or we should do as
little of that as we possibly can that
doesn't mean we shouldn't take a look at
these bigger structural issues but we
shouldn't cram it all together in one
thing because it's not that's very well
put jordan that's exactly what i'm
trying to say you said it better than i
did
well i listened to you so that was a big
help by the way if we do cram it all
into one thing god help us because there
are people uh and and they're not going
to speak out there are people uh who
will see it process it just as i hope
they would not do black thug murders
innocent white girl and and and harbor a
resentment and nurse that resentment and
that's a tinder box that's a powder keg
waiting to be lit and we can dismiss it
if we want to but those people are not
entirely wrong
in their sentiment they they need to be
disabused of that instinct that that
that instinct to conflate those levels
of analysis yeah yeah yeah well that's
part of the problem i have with ideology
is that that's
ideology is so low resolution it it does
that conflation it doesn't notice
and when you get educated you start
differentiating it's like and that's
kind of what you said happened to you
when you became more conservative once
you got more educated it's like oh oh
this is when i take this apart and see
all the moving pieces this is way more
complex than my low resolution
representation guided me to believe to
begin with and that's that i mean i've
experienced that many times in my life
when i tried to take problems apart so
they could be solved instead of just
discussed let's say you have to make a
high resolution model before you can get
anywhere that's true in clinical
practice and i think it's true in public
policy and partly what we're doing when
we're educating people if we're doing it
right is saying hey you know you've got
a map of the world but it's it's not
very detailed and when you really look
at it well you know here's the
complexity
and that's what we're actually
contending with people don't like that
because well it's complex right and you
have the simple solution at hand to
begin with but the problem is it it
isn't the right tool for the job
you got to make it high resolution now
it takes a lot of work